ALL RIGHT!
WELL, IT WAS THE WORST OF TIMES,
IT WAS THE WORST OF TIMES.
THE UNITED STATES TODAY, IT'S
WATERGATE, 9/11, THE CIVIL WAR,
THE POTATO FAMINE, AND THE
CANCELLATION OF
"SEX AND THE CITY," ALL ROLLED
INTO ONE.
THANK GOD, DUE TO TIME AND
CHANGE, THE WORLD IS SUPPOSED TO
END IN A YEAR.
THAT REMINDS ME, I HAVE TO PICK
UP MY SHIRTS AT THE CLEANERS.
SO WHY IS A READING SO BAD?
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN THE AGE OF
HYPERBOLE.
IN FACT, SOME SAY WE ARE LIVING
IN THE GREATEST, MOST INCREDIBLE
ERA OF HYPERBOLE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF TIME.
USING EXTREME RHETORIC TO SCARE
YOU INTO SUBMISSION.
IF YOU DO NOT WEAR A MASK
OUTSIDE WHILE JOGGING YOU HAVE
BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS.
IF YOU SUPPORT THE COPS THAT YOU
ARE A RACIST WITH BLOOD ON YOUR
HANDS.
IF YOU CUT YOUR FINGERS SLICING
TOMATOES, -- THAT WOULD BE RIGH,
YOU WOULD HAVE BLOOD ON YOUR
HANDS.
EVEN MORE, IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
JOE, YOU MIGHT AS WELL BE
JEFFERSON DAVIS HIMSELF.
>> THE ASSAULT ON FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS IS JUST SUCH A THREAT,
LITERALLY.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE.
WE ARE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
THAT'S NOT HYPERBOLE.
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Greg: HE IS NOT WELL.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE BIDEN LITERALLY DOESN'T KNOW
THE MEANING OF THE WORD
"LITERALLY."
I MEAN, HE SAYS IT IS NOT
HYPERBOLE BECAUSE HE KNEW IT WAS
HYPERBOLE THE MOMENT HE SAID IT.
YOU COULD SAY HE HAS HYPERBOLE
ON THE BRAIN, AND BOY, HYPERBOLE
MUST BE VERY LONELY.
IT'S WEIRD HOW A MONTH OF
CHALLENGING A CONTENTIOUS
ELECTION MAKES YOU WORSE THAN A
PROSLAVERY, CONFEDERATE
FLAG-WAVING, NONRECYCLING
DEMOCRAT.
BUT JOE'S PARTY SPENT FOUR YEARS
DOING THE SAME THING WITH THE
2016 ELECTION.
THE IRONY IS THICKER THAN BRIAN
STELTER'S THIGHS.
DON'T JUDGE, YOU KNOW IT IS
TRUE.
THE HYPERBOLE CONTINUES.
LET'S SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING OVER
AT CNN, SHALL WE?
>> THE CIVIL WAR, THAT'S NOT
EVEN CLOSE.
>> NO, THIS IS WORSE THAN WHEN
LEE HARVEY OSWALD SHOT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
>> IT IS WORSE THAN WHEN THE
HINDENBURG CRASHED INTO THE
ICEBERG.
>> IT IS WORSE THAN WHEN ALL OF
THE GOOD SOLDIERS LOST THEIR
LIVES IN THE BATTLE OF
CHERNOBYL.
>> WORSE THAN WHEN THE VILLAGERS
OF POMPEII GOT WIPED OUT BY THE
BP OIL SPILL.
>> TRIED TO COVER UP WATERGATE.
>> Greg: LITTLE KNOWN FACT.
NOW REMEMBER, DURING THE
CIVIL WAR, THOSE CONFEDERATE
DEMOCRATS MAY HAVE OWNED SLAVES,
BUT THEY NEVER PUT ON RED HATS,
WANDERED INTO THE CAPITOL, AND
STOLE OFFICE SUPPLIES FROM
JERRY NADLER.
>> CONFEDERATES, BACK THEN,
NEVER BREACHED THE CAPITOL.
AS INSURRECTIONIST DID ON
JANUARY THE 6TH.
I'M NOT SAYING THIS TO ALARM
YOU.
I AM SAYING THIS BECAUSE YOU
SHOULD BE ALARMED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: SO WAIT A SECOND,
POWELL.
JANUARY 6TH SHOULDN'T HAVE
ALARMED YOU BECAUSE BY
JANUARY 6TH, YOU SHOULD HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ALARMED.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THAT BRAIN?
BUT TRUE, WE WERE ALREADY
ALARMED, WHEN YOU, MR. MAGOO,
WON THE ELECTION.
YOU CLAIM YOU WERE A UNIFIER AS
YOU DEEM TO HALF THE COUNTRY A
BUNCH OF NAZIS.
HOW IS THIS RHETORIC NOW NOT
INCITEMENT?
BUT KEEP GOING.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT IN MY ENTIRE
CAREER I WOULD HAVE TO SAY, BUTO
GOD, TO PRESERVE, PROTECT, AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION, AND
THAT IS AN OATH THAT FORMS A
SACRED TRUST TO DEFEND AMERICA
AGAINST ALL THREATS, BOTH
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
>> Greg: OH, MAN.
DUDE, YOU WOULD NOT KNOW IF
FOREIGN THREAT IF A SHIRTLESS
PUTIN RODE HIS HORSE INTO THE
OVAL OFFICE AND TOOK A DUMP ON
YOUR DESK.
SO THE PROBLEM WE FACE AS
AMERICANS TODAY ISN'T US, IT'S
THE RIGHT MISDIAGNOSIS.
RUSSIA AND CHINA ARE BOTH
ENGAGING IN CYBER WARFARE, CUBA
IS LOOKING LIKE IT IS READY TO
BLOW, AND HAITI'S PRESIDENT WAS
JUST FOUND DEAD WITH 12 BULLETS
IN HIM -- IN OTHER WORDS,
NATURAL CAUSES.
AND IN A DANK PRISON CELL
SOMEWHERE SITS A GUY WHO WORE
HORNS ON HIS HEAD AT THE
CAPITAL.
BUT WHO DOES OUR FEARLESS,
FORMERLY HAIRLESS
COMMANDER IN CHIEF SEE AS BEING
THE CHIEF THREAT?
YOU AND ME.
AND THE NETWORK, SURPRISE,
SURPRISE, AGREE.
SPEAK OF THE QUESTIONS OF WHEN,
WHERE, AND HOW AMERICANS GET TO
VOTE ARE TONIGHT TAKING ON
GREATER URGENCY, AND SOME OF HIS
STRONGEST LANGUAGE YET,
PRESIDENT BIDEN
TODAY BLASTING REPUBLICAN
EFFORTS TO RESTRICT VOTING
ACCESS AS UN-AMERICAN AND A TEST
OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN LATE TODAY IN
PHILADELPHIA, THE BIRTHPLACE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, BLASTING
WHAT HE CALLS ATTACKS ON VOTING
RIGHTS.
REPUBLICAN LED EFFORTS AND MORE
THAN 16 STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, THE PRESIDENT
WARNING, CALLING IT THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR,
SAYING THESE NEW LAWS AIMED TO
LIMIT WHETHER OR NOT YOUR VOTE
COUNTS AT ALL.
>> Greg: OH, SO SOLEMN.
SO HE PAINTS TARGETS ON YOU AND
THE MEDIA APPLAUDS.
ANYWAY, WE LIVE IN A TIME WERE
RATHER THAN USE CLEAR, PLAIN
LANGUAGE TO DEBATE AN ISSUE, WE
RESORT TO LANGUAGE OF LAWSUITS.
JOE BIDEN HAS TURNED OUR COUNTRY
INTO AN EPISODE OF DIVORCE
COURT, THROWING AROUND TERMS
LIKE VICIOUS AND UNCONSCIONABLE.
THE DEMS ACCUSED EVERYONE OF
EVERY HORRIBLE THING IMAGINABLE
UNTIL YOU SLING IT RIGHT BACK AT
THEM.
THAN THEY GO FROM "WELL, YOU ARE
AN EVIL MONSTER" TO "WE ASK
YOU RESPECT OUR PRIVATE KNOW MY
FAMILY'S PRIVACY."
THIS INCENDIARY LANGUAGE IS
SPREADING ON TWITTER, AND ITS
STENCH IS PRESENT IN EVERY
ONLINE PETITION DEMANDING A
BOYCOTT.
THE TARGETS ARE ALWAYS RACIST,
INTOLERANT, AUTHORITARIAN
MONSTERS, EVEN WHEN THEY'RE NOT
IN POWER.
>> WHAT WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
WITH TRUMP WAS THAT HE WAS
CRAZY, AND HE IS STILL CRAZY,
AND HE WAS UNHINGED, AND YOU
NEED TO BRING THE WHOLE SYSTEM
DOWN, HE HAS ALL OF THESE
AUTHORITARIAN TENDENCIES.
>> Greg: IT IS LIKE AN IV DRIP
OF CONCENTRATED TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME IS THE ONLY
THING KEEPING THAT DESICCATED
HUSK ALIVE.
[LAUGHTER]
NEVER GET TO SAY "HUSK" ENOUGH.
AND I WERE HYSTERIC IN SHEEP'S
RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
>> 21ST CENTURY JIM CROW ASSAULT
IS REAL, IT IS UNRELENTING, AND
WE ARE GOING TO CHALLENGE IT
VIGOROUSLY.
WHAT WE ASK OF MY REPUBLICAN
FRIENDS IN CONGRESS, STATES,
CITIES, COUNTIES, TO STAND UP,
FOR GOD'S SAKE, AND HELP PREVENT
THIS CONCERTED EFFORT TO
UNDERMINE OUR ELECTION.
AND THE SACRED RIGHT TO VOTE.
HAVE YOU KNOW SHAME?
>> Greg: "HAVE YOU KNOW
SHAME?"
ASKS THE HAIR SNIFFING, RACE
BADER.
AS A NEW REPORT REVEALS OUR NAVY
IS UNPREPARED TO DEFEND OUR
COUNTRY BUT FULL SPEED AHEAD ON
ANTIRACISM, WE ARE TOLD THE
ENEMY IS WITHIN, NEVER MIND
RUSSIA CHINA, WHICH BOASTS THE
WORLD'S MOST FEARSOME NAVY PIER
FOR THE REAL MONSTERS DRIVE
CHEVY TRUCKS, WHERE RED HATS,
AND LISTEN TO TOBY KEITH.
WE MUST ALL GO WILL OR WILL
NEVER SHED OUR EVIL PASTS.
RATHER THAN LOOK FORWARD, WE
FOCUS ON EXORCISING DEMONS FROM
THE PAST, ALL PUT FORTH BY
DEMOCRATS.
WHEN WE INEVITABLY BECOME THE
FAILED SUPERPOWER, AT LEAST WE
WILL KNOW WHY, WE DESERVE IT,
BECAUSE WE WERE WORSE THAN THOSE
MURDEROUS, CONFEDERATE
SLAVE OWNERS THEIR CORRUPT,
SEGREGATIONIST -- IN OTHER
WORDS, DEMOCRATS.
HOW IS THAT FOR HYPERBOLE?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THERE HE IS!
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST!
SHE HAS SENT MORE CRIMINALS UP
THE RIVER THEN A BOAT CARRYING
THE CLINTONS.
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
YOU ARE A CROWD FAVORITE.
HE KNOWS THE FELT WAY LIKE I
KNOW THE BELTWAY.
GUY BENSON.
LIFEGUARD, LAWYER, MODEL, SHE
HANDLES MORE JOBS THEN
SUPERGLUE, TURNING POINT USA
CONTRIBUTOR AARON ELMORE.
AND HER BEHAVIOR HAS STEROID
USERS SAYING THAT IS NOT BECAUSE
OF STEROIDS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR CAPPED
HIM.
JUDGE, IT IS A PLEASURE TO HAVE
YOU HERE.
IT IS LIKE I ONLY SAW YOU A FEW
HOURS AGO ON "THE FIVE."
>> IT WAS LESS THAN THAT.
>> Greg: WE NEED TO SPEND MORE
TIME TOGETHER.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: VACATIONS?
PEOPLE THINK YOU AND I HANG OUT.
>> WE DON'T HANG OUT, BECAUSE
YOU NEVER INVITE ME.
>> Greg: YOU WOULD NOT LIKE
THE THINGS I DO.
>> SURPRISED AT THE THINGS YOU
DO.
>> Greg: SHE IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
SO GEORGE, THIS RHETORIC --
OKAY, TRUMP GOT A LOT OF GRIEF,T
HE ALWAYS WENT AFTER PEOPLE THAT
WERE, LIKE COME ON HIS LEVEL, HE
WOULD GO AFTER JIM ACOSTA, THE
PRESS, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT
WOULD NOT LABEL PEOPLE, LIKE, HE
WOULD NOT SAY "BIDEN VOTERS
SUCK" OR "HILLARY VOTERS SUCKS,"
HE WAS FOCUSED ON PEOPLE WHO
COULD FIGHT.
BIDEN IS LIKE LABELING PEOPLE
AS, LIKE, BASICALLY AS BAD AS
SLAVE OWNERS AND CONFEDERATE
SOLDIERS.
>> WELL, YEAH, THE HYPERBOLE, AS
YOU TALK ABOUT IT, IS ABOUT
MAKING ALL OF US FEEL THAT WE
ARE RACIST, WE ARE OPPRESSORS,
WE ARE HORRIBLE PEOPLE, AND HE
REFERENCES THE CIVIL WAR.
THE CIVIL WAR WAS ABOUT NOT
BEING RACIST.
IT WAS ABOUT MAKING SURE PEOPLE
WEREN'T ANYMORE.
HE USES THAT IT IS AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT IS UN-AMERICAN.
HE HAS REALLY LOST IT.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS GO TO
WASHINGTON AND WHAT THEY DO IS
LEARN PHRASES, YOU ARE
UN-AMERICAN, OPPRESSOR, RACIST,
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
BILLS, ANYTHING ABOUT THE LAWS,
THEY JUST KNOW ABOUT
NAME-CALLING.
IT'S ALL THEY DO.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO SAY,
GUY, BOTH SIDES, I'M GOING TO
SAY THIS AND THEN CONTRADICT
MYSELF, BOTH SIDES CAN BE GUILTY
OF HYPERBOLE.
WE SAW A LOT OF HYPERBOLE DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION COMING
FROM THE RIGHT.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS
DIFFERENT, BECAUSE OUR HYPERBOLE
IS ALWAYS BASED ON THINKING
SOMEBODY IS WRONG.
BUT THERE HOSTILITY AND
HYPERBOLE IS BASED ON
THINKING WE ARE ABLE.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THIS?
WHY IS BIDEN SAYING THE STUFF?
>> I THINK HE WANTED TO GIVE A
VERY ANGRY SEEMING SPEECH TO
PAPER OVER THE FACT HE IS NOT
CALLING FOR THE FILIBUSTER TO GO
AWAY.
I THINK HE IS TRYING TO DO A
SHINY OBJECT OF THE LEFT, BUT
NOT ACTUALLY DOING A STRUCTURAL
THING THEY WANT HIM TO DO, BUT
THAT IS THE SERIOUS ANSWER.
BUT THE MORE SERIOUS THING I
HAVE TO SAY, I THINK THIS SHOW
RIGHT NOW IS AN ASSAULT ON
DEMOCRACY, REALLY.
AND THIS CONVERSATION MAY BE THE
WORST THING THAT HAS HAPPENED
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
>> AND YOU SHOULD ALL BE ASHAMED
OF YOURSELVES FOR BEING PART OF
IT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
NOW, BUT WAIT UNTIL THE B BLOCK.
IT'S GOING TO BE WORSE THAN THE
A.
>> I CANNOT HELP BUT NOTICE ALL
OF THE LADIES ARE WEARING WHITE.
IS THAT PERHAPS A LITTLE
INDICATION --
>> I AM SO ASHAMED OF MYSELF.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE, BUT THE
GIRLS ARE WEARING CAMOUFLAGE
PANTS.
>> I AM DOING IT FOR THE TROOPS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I BET YOU THEY APPRECIATE IT.
>> I MARRIED A VETERAN, YOU
KNOW, SUPPORT THE TROOPS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SUPPORTING
ONE TROOP.
ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING TO GO TALK
TO OUR NEW GUEST, SO YOU JUST
SIT THERE AND BE POLITE.
>> OKAY, I'LL TRY.
>> Greg: WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
THE PLEASURE IS ALL YOURS.
>> Greg: I AM GLAD YOU WORE
WHITE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
CIVIL WAR CLAIM, AND HOW IS --
HOW DOES THIS HELP THE DEMOCRATS
AT ALL?
>> BASICALLY, THIS IS LIKE IN
EPISODE OF "THE REAL HOUSE
DEMOCRATS."
A WHOLE SEASON.
HE DOES NOT KNOW WHAT HYPERBOLE
IS, IT'S NOT 31 FLAVORS OF
BASKIN-ROBBINS APPEARED HE
THOUGHT TEXAS' VOTING LAW WAS
TOO COMPLICATED, MAKE IT TOO
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE, SO
IT IS COMPLICATED WITH GETTING A
FLAT TIRE OR A CAVITY FILLED?
THOSE THINGS ARE COMPLICATED AND
INCONVENIENT.
SHOWING YOUR I.D. TO VOTE IS
PRETTY STANDARD FARE, SO WHAT
DOES HE WANT, DOES HE WANT, I
DON'T KNOW, A BOOTH WITH LITTLE
GIRLS WHERE HE CAN SNIFF THEIR
HAIR AND THEY CAN HAVE
HUNTER BIDEN FINGER PAINT TO
SHOW OFF WHILE HE IS WAITING TO
VOTE?
>> Greg: HAVE TO FACT-CHECK,
THOSE ARE NOT FINGER PAINTS.
A STRAW.
>> HE'S GOT A LOT OF PRACTICE.
OKAY.
>> Greg: SO, CAT, I FEEL IF I
WAS WATCHING SOMETHING LIKE CNN,
I WOULD FEEL -- THERE IS ALWAYS
A NEW EXISTENTIAL RISK.
>> IT IS SO DRAMATIC.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT TALKING TO
REALLY REPUBLICANS ABOUT THIS
STUFF, HE IS JUST SAYING, MAKING
THESE SUPER DRAMATIC PUBLIC
PRONOUNCEMENTS, LIKE IF YOU HAVE
A FRIEND -- YOU CANCELED THAT
HER PLANS WITH HER AND SHE IS
LIKE "THAT'S FINE" AND YOU GO ON
HER INSTAGRAM, TOXIC FRIENDS,
DON'T -- IT IS LIKE MY FRIEND IS
IN THE HOSPITAL, JESSICA.
IT IS WORSE BECAUSE IT IS
TEARING THE COUNTRY APART OVER
STUFF THAT IS NOT TRUE AND IS
DRAMATIC, WHICH IS WAY WORSE
THAN JESSICA GOING AND TALKING
TO SARAH ABOUT YOU BEHIND --
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THE
COUNTRY NOTICES THIS BIFURCATING
NONSENSE OR JUST BECAUSE WE ARE
IN THIS BUSINESS?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK IT IS
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THIS BUSINESS.
PEOPLE, THEY HAVE OTHER JOBS --
>> Greg: I WOULD SAY
FORTUNATELY.
>> WELL, YEAH, THEY'D HAVE TO
SIT THERE AND READ -- I LOVE MY
JOB, I AM THE LUCKIEST GIRL IN
THE WORLD.
>> Greg: YOU ARE.
WHO WOULDN'T WANT TO WORK WITH
ME?
RIGHT, JUDGE?
>> YEAH, I LOVE WORKING WITH
YOU.
>> Greg: DO YOU REALLY?
>> NO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I THINK THEY BELIEVE IT AND
THE PEOPLE GET SO AMPED UP IN A
COUNTRY TORN APART, YOU
SUPPORT -- THEN YOU LIKE
SLAVERY!
AND PEOPLE THINK THOSE THINGS.
BUT I THINK IT IS NOT JUST
PEOPLE WHO WATCH -- I THINK
EVERYBODY ISN'T MAD OUT THERE.
YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE, LIKE RIGHT
NOW WHEN I DRIVE, I DON'T GET
UPSET, I DON'T BLOW THE HORN, I
AM AFRAID SOMEONE IS GOING --
STOP IT.
WHAT ARE YOU LAUGHING AT?
SO I DON'T SAY ANYTHING.
IT IS LIKE EVERYBODY IS SO NUTS,
YOU ARE AFRAID THEY'RE GOING TO
COME AT YOU.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOU DRIVING
THESE DAYS?
>> AN AIRPLANE.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOU DRIVING?
>> I'M DRIVING MY SUV WI